and that's the honest answer and this is
the new book now let me tell you what i
really think on your in your book stores
very soon if this is tuesday it's not
sooner amazon i think it's already at
the uh barnes noble i think it's already
there chris matthews on his way to his
book tour thank you very much thanks for
having me first nice to have you here
it's about two minutes past the hour mr
matthews will be unplugged here and
we're going to continue talking about a
story that was in the wall street
journal on september the 27th the year
2001 it was on page three
and those of you who watched this
program many of you saw the story and we
want to get an opportunity now to find
out exactly what was in the story and
how the author of it came to the
information daniel golden good morning
in boston good morning uh thanks for
having me
tell us about this story what's the what
were the basics that you had in it
well the number of the story was about
the relationship between the bin laden
family's company which is the saudi bin
laden group
and it's its relationship to the
carlisle group which is a washington
merchant bank
that
does specializes in leveraged buyouts of
defense contractors
the bin laden group is a small investor
in the carlisle group and as a result it
uh it's also become quite friendly with
and associated with a bunch of
republican leaders uh because the
carlisle group among the heavyweights
connected with it our former secretary
of defense uh frank salvucci frank
carlucci
uh former secretary of state james baker
and a former president george bush
how did you get on to this story
well we had done a previous story about
the bin laden group's connections with
uh companies in the united states
via their website which they've since
taken down they listed a bunch of
american and western companies that
they'd done business with and that kind
of led me naturally to looking at some
of their political connections and some
of their other investments
now the carlisle group
based here in washington is it a public
company
uh i don't believe so i believe it's
privately held how much information were
you able to get directly from them when
you went after the story
well not a great deal of information but
uh you know they did confirm that the
bin laden group was and it was an
investor
and what about the connection between
the former president and you mentioned
in your in your story that he had a
couple meetings with the bin laden
family and how
when you first went after it though they
told you only one in 1998
yeah that's right i think his his aides
said that just that his memory is not as
good as it once was
uh they only owned up to one meeting at
that time and later they acknowledged
two meetings uh the reason being that i
had some evidence of the two meetings
i'd been uh
shown some thank you notes that the
former president and mr uh
carlucci and mr baker and so on had
written after visiting the bin laden
group's home and headquarters in saudi
arabia uh you know most these officials
in the last few years or former
government officials had visited there
on business related to the carlisle
group and had met the head of the bin
laden family and some of the other
brothers
why would people who had received these
thank you notes from the former
president and others show them to you
well i think they would show them to me
because the uh the bin laden group is is
very worried about its name you know
they know that their brother obviously
is a notorious the world over and so i
think they show these notes to people
with whom they want to do business in
order to uh convince them that they're a
legitimate company and that they're not
some kind of terrorist front now people
watching this show some people leaped to
the conclusion uh immediately
that uh this interconnection with the
bin laden family is helping to benefit
the bush family that george bush in the
white house has a direct benefit to all
this and the conspiracy theorists
suggest that uh i mean the farthest
charge you might as well get it on the
table is that this was all created by
the bush family for their own personal
benefit want to deal with that
well i i don't know of any evidence to
substantiate any conspiracy theory i
think that uh you know wealthy saudi
arabian businessmen with money to invest
have long had a lot of access to uh you
know our ruling elite and that this is
really no different and that these
american officials were persuaded that
the
bin laden family uh you know had had uh
completely disowned or had a complete
rupture with usama and uh they saw no
harm in uh financial partnership with
them do you get any sense of how much
money is made at the carlyle group off
of the connection with the bin laden
group
well the bin laden investment appears to
be pretty small they're in one
particular fund and
according to the carlyle group they only
put two million dollars in it which is
pretty small because it's a fund of over
a billion dollars um other sources i
have indicate that it may be more than
two million but i don't think anybody
feels they're a huge investor i think in
a way that the bin laden connection has
helped the carlyle group more because it
opens a lot of doors in saudi arabia uh
you know the bin ladens are very close
to the royal family in saudi arabia
they're one of the you know half dozen
wealthiest families there and uh
you know their name there is like uh
rockefeller or something it just opens a
lot of doors you point out in your story
that former president jimmy carter has
met with 10 of osama's brothers early in
2000 what's that about
well uh jimmy carter went there i went
to
jeddah saudi arabia where the bin ladens
are based he was looking for
contributions to the carter center uh i
believe for some uh
health program to a combat disease in
the third world and uh he negotiated
with the bin ladens in saudi arabia and
then later he and rosalind carter uh met
with some of the bin ladens in new york
city and uh they they eventually
received a two hundred thousand dollar
donation to the carter center you
obviously thought this story was
important or you wouldn't even have gone
after written what do you think the
what's the conclusion after you've done
this story what should the american
people think about this well i think
there's two aspects to it that are
important one is
uh i mean they they are uh usama's
family and although they they have
disowned him and there's been a rupture
uh you know it's still worth pursuing uh
whether there's a relationship there
uh clearly the brothers who who head the
family uh are not in contact with them
and have disowned them but it's a big
family there's something like uh
54 brothers and sisters or 53 in in that
realm
and some of them may be in contact with
osama
also i think it's been reported that one
of usama's brother-in-law a husband of
one of his sisters
was regarded as a terrorist by
philippine police
that guy is now living in saudi arabia
i'm not sure on what terms he is with
the family but i think it's worth uh
exploring and asking whether everybody
in the family is as resolute in their
denunciation of usama as the heads of
the family are
the the other there's another meaning
too which uh
uh you know it's part of i think a total
uh
issue of the united states is
relationship with the ruling saudi
arabian elite uh you know that elite is
has long been accused of corruption and
nepotism and the like and uh the bin
ladens are so close to saudi royal
family that being cozy with the bin
ladens may reflect an overall problem
and sort of our relationship with saudi
arabia and its government and its people
daniel golden is in boston what you see
behind him there on that picture to
still picture is the harbor at boston he
is a native of amherst massachusetts a
harvard graduate has been a reporter
since 1999 at the wall street journal
before that 18 years with the boston
globe we take our first call from
santiago chile this morning go ahead
please santiago you're on the air
thank you
my name is gina i'm from santiago chile
um i'm glad to hear your program it's
very interesting um
there are two things that uh
um at least i think here what we have
the feeling that america has been
a little bit weak under politic you have
all these huge developments and
technology
um and you have israel in the middle
east that can help why don't you cut it
down more quickly more force and that's
it you know we live in the end of the
world here in south america we belong to
the jewish community and we're always
afraid we have to take care of the
children at school doing guard around
even having anything here but it all the
time affect us i think you have the
whole technology to put and cut down
this stuff quickly okay thanks uh mr
golden is here as a guest to talk about
the article that he wrote about the
carlisle group and the bin laden family
and george herbert walker bush uh you're
free to say anything you want to about
this call if you uh but if you don't
want it we can just move on
well i think that uh you know my overall
comment would just be that it's
difficult to be strong when when you're
not precisely sure who the enemy is and
where they are and
i'm sure if we were more certain about
that we'd probably be acting more
strongly when you did your story on the
bin laden group and the bushes uh
people willing to talk to you at every
stop
no uh you know james baker declined
comment uh frank carlucci declined
comment i mean a lot of people are
clearly uh
embarrassed now to have their uh
connections with the bin laden family uh
revealed
centerville virginia you're next
first of all i'd like to thank brian for
your integrity and honesty in this
programming
thank you mr golden uh
i'm familiar i have read things on the
internet
overseas websites concerning the
carlisle group and the bin laden
connection
but i was wondering have you read
anything about the inside trading that
went on
shortly after the attacks we heard about
it and we haven't heard anything else
since and i was wondering if you had
read anything or heard insider trading
by uh what group
well that's what we don't know
i've probably read some of the same
reports you have but i don't know if
they're uh accurate or not i haven't
really researched that when you did your
story how active uh was the carlisle
group and by the way we asked the
carlyle group to come on and respond to
all this and they didn't uh return their
our our phone calls and we tried all day
yesterday um at least when i left the
office they may have come in late but
how how active were they in answering
your questions
well uh
they did not want to answer them by name
they they had one of their top
executives uh talk to me on a uh not for
a use of the name basis and uh you know
on that basis they were uh fairly
forthcoming but as i say there's this
unresolved dispute over uh how much
money the bin ladens actually have in
their fund and how deep the relationship
goes and i think it's too bad that they
weren't able to come on camera and
discuss it further are there any other
people that you know of associated with
the carlyle group
who have passed connections with any
administration besides frank carlucci
and jim baker and george herbert walker
bush i believe there are some former uh
reagan and bush administration officials
uh
on their uh board of directors and his
advisors uh uh i don't have the list
with me but uh i believe uh richard
dharman perhaps and there's some others
tampa florida for dan golden of the wall
street journal good morning brian my
comment is to you first
did you have any solid evidence before
you invited this rhetoric on your tv
that you have brian did you find
evidence
and the instigation that you
spilled out this morning was uh maybe it
was something to do with the campaign or
the
this is not right brian
you're being biased against president
bush
now i have a question for the gentleman
there yeah well the question about bias
is the gentleman on the screen from
boston dan golden wrote the article a
lot of people have called this program
since the article came out this is your
opportunity to talk directly with him
please go ahead exactly and i it's my
opportunity to question you too go right
ahead okay
and now you are a disgrace to journalism
first of all
you need evidence to before you start
spewing and writing about our president
and how our former president
and this is a your disgrace why didn't
you
publish anything about how gore and
clinton sold
our secrets to china caller let me ask
you a question uh what evidence do you
want beyond what he's actually written
so far what has he written what has he
written so far
that is is incorrect or is uh against
what you think he should write brian my
opinion my
question to you
did you have any evidence before you
invited this guest on your show evidence
for what ma'am but what is the the
incorrect fact that he's spewing out
what incorrect facts is he spewing out
because this is not he's the only
journalist that's ever brought anything
like this into into the public's eye why
does that make him incorrect
why haven't you it's back to you again
maybe i could uh let if i could speak to
this for a minute um as brian pointed
out the story appeared september 27th
you know in a prominent publication the
wall street journal nobody has asked for
any correction or raised any question of
accuracy about the story since then
as i indicated it's undisputed that
these various political leaders visited
the bin laden family in the last few
years now there's one aspect on which
other publications have gone farther
than my story did and on which uh i was
very careful
about 20 years ago uh
the older brother one of the older
brothers of osama bin laden uh salim bin
laden
he frequented texas he spent a lot of
time there
and he had business interests there and
he had a business representative named
jim bath
now mr bath was a
close friend of our current president
george w bush and uh invested in a
couple of funds that uh
uh mr bush then then controlled oil
related funds now a number of
publications have leaked to the
conclusion that therefore mr bath was
investing
bin laden money in these bush oil funds
but i can tell you that you know we
found no evidence that it was anything
other than mr bath's own money
and as mr bath has claimed on numerous
occasions
and uh you know so we uh wrote the story
we were very careful to indicate that
there was no uh indication of a
financial connection between the bin
ladens and george w bush let me go back
to our caller for a moment in tampa
caller let me ask you a question again
though nobody said that anybody's done
anything wrong here why are you upset
brian may i suggest one more thing and i
thank you for taking this
would you mind answering my question
i said nobody's nobody said anything
anybody's done anything wrong here why
are you upset
what is he publishing what is this uh
rhetoric that he's publishing about our
former president what's rhetoric about
this
what's what's rhetorical about this
brian it's exactly what he's stating in
his column okay i'm going to let you go
uh mr golden you want to follow up on
anything
no i think that uh you know she's
concerned about perhaps
us implying some kind of guilt by
association and no you know we didn't do
that we simply laid out the facts and i
think it's important for the public to
know them kenosha wisconsin for dan
golden you're on the air
thank you very much
i would like to ask mr golden the
question there's a rumor flying around
wisconsin
that the bin laden family and the
carlisle group
have a joint venture
project to build a pipeline
from all the former
soviet union stand states
to the arabian sea
and that pipeline would have to go
through again afghanistan
which puts whole new light on the
situation of why we might be there
anything on that mr golden i never heard
of that let's go to san diego next for
dan gold in the wall street journal
you're on the air yes hi good morning i
think the story is very interesting and
we could add a sequel which is full
cooperation in between clinton
administration and bin laden people in
bosnia these people have a airport built
by clinton administration they were
supplied arms through croatia and
slovenia into the bosnian war and even
as we speak american embassy in boston
is closed
due to the uh then london's threat
anything about this do you know of mr
golden i don't i don't really know about
that either i mean obviously our foreign
policy in relation to osama bin laden's
been fluid i mean years ago in
afghanistan when they were fighting the
soviet union we were on the same side
but
i i don't know anything about the
bosnian situation in particular how
often have you found uh that former
political uh people or or people in our
government have done business than with
the countries that they were uh
engaged with when they were in an
administration and is it only a
republican administration that does this
well uh
as i think you know we mentioned before
uh jimmy carter obviously uh solicited a
gift from the uh from the uh bin laden
group and i would think that officials
of uh you know both parties once they
leave office uh you know nobody is uh
neither party is totally free of people
who probably uh
link up afterwards for financial reasons
do i have dallas on the line
uh yes sir you're you're on with dan
goldman go ahead please
uh mr golden uh this pipeline was gonna
start in turkmenistan
and the biggest gas field in the world
it was going to run down through
afghanistan
through pakistan down the arabian gulf
they were going to build an oil pipeline
and a gas pipeline
it's going to cost 5 billion dollars
the saudi bin laden company was going to
be a major participant in it
it's all about money
follow the money
talk to jeff fowler of your farm desk
he's got all the information on it mr
golden well i'm glad to hear we're all
over that story and uh you know all i
can tell you in that in that realm is
that you know the saudi bin laden group
is a predominantly construction company
in the middle east they have had
interest in getting into oil exploration
and they had a joint venture with i
believe it's hc price or hg price
company uh which has a texas office
uh in the mid 1990s to do oil
exploration but from what i was told
they they failed to win contracts and so
ultimately the the joint venture ended
around 1997 or 1998. mr gold when was
the first time you had any inclination
that this was a story for you
well go far as far back as you can well
you know my normal beat is actually uh
covering education so i'm not a lifelong
student of the bin ladens
after seven september 11th uh you know i
was scrambling to to help out in the
coverage and uh you know i thought of uh
looking a little bit at the bin laden
family business and as i said
on their website they listed uh just a
multitude of companies in the in the
west that they do business with i
thought they were just a construction
company in the middle east it turns out
they're a reseller of all kinds of
things telecommunications equipment food
and beverages from american companies
like motorola nortel which is canadian
picturetel
and so i got interested in that and i
began to cultivate some contacts among
the uh
uh bin laden family and uh spokespeople
for the bin laden family and uh you know
financial people who deal with them and
once i realized that uh
these former uh once i was told that
these former american leaders or
officials
were uh meeting with the bin ladens and
once i learned that the carlyle group
was predominantly uh defense industry
oriented you know you'd have to be uh
kind of a fool journalistically not to
see that the idea of the bin laden
family having an investment in the
american defense industry you know was
was not a story because it obviously was
did you find vice president cheney in
his former life with halliburton
anywhere in that story
uh i didn't in relation with the bin
ladens in particular though i would say
that that might uh might bear more
scrutiny i i know that they've you know
there's been some contacts there between
halliburton and and saudi arabian
families in general but i don't know
about the bin laden specifically black
hill ecuador for dan golden of the wall
street journal you're on the air
yes thank you and good morning for such
a creative program but i wanted to say
that right after the election i went
into the internet on the google.com
and i traced it the bing ladies the
bushes everybody there's so many
corporations in which american
businessmen are representing these
families and these ventures in the
middle east and all over and it's about
excavation exploration oil and so forth
and so on this is in the internet this
is all over the books i think mr golden
just brought it into a major journal a
newspaper but people want to be blind so
all you have to do is go to the internet
and follow so many leaps and you will
see that there is definitely something
inappropriate and i feel bad for what is
going on in america but sometimes uh you
know guild relies on whatever uh
people or companies are trying to do
business to the expense of maybe
compromising friendship or security so i
applaud mr golden's book and more
americans should come and speak about
these things mr golden congratulations
and also to the host to the program mr
golden is there a possible way for
people to get your story is it still on
an internet somewhere that they can get
it it should be on the uh wall street
journal website
you know it was september the 27th
that's right and what kind of reaction
did you get from the story well it's
been interesting it's been kind of a
delayed reaction i mean when the story
originally ran i didn't get much of any
and then you know in the last week to 10
days i've been getting more phone calls
more emails it seems to have taken a
while to kind of
catch on which is which is pretty
unusual in my experience has anybody fed
you new information in this process that
you're interested in pursuing yeah we
have a couple leads and you know if they
uh uh you know if they pan out we may do
another story with a group like the
carlyle group how can you get to the
bottom of what they are and who's on
their board and how much money they make
is it possible if they're not a public
company
well uh
you know it's not um it's not easy i
mean there's a lot of information on
their website there's a lot of
executives who used to be at the carlyle
group and have now left you know the
typical journalistic ways of trying to
look into something san diego for dan
golden of the wall street journal good
morning you're on the air yes good
morning i i salute mr golden simply
because
he's doing investigative reporting which
is becoming a dinosaur it seems in in
this in this country
um
the woman who had all of the fear of
any discussion would not answer any
questions about how or how in fact
what was being reported
was uh was an offense
typically is what is what the climate is
becoming
i i just recently
asked to unsubscribe from
you comics when they canceled boondocks
and then i was told
because i said i would not
to to resubscribe me when the censorship
stopped that my name had my name all of
our names had been forwarded to the fbi
so
within this climate we've got to have
more and more people and i teach 1984
and this is what i told them we have to
have more and more people who will who
will not be afraid to investigate issues
thanks caller you you having a receptive
desk there at the wall street journal
for more investigative reporting oh yeah
the journal is always very interested in
a good investigative story
when uh when you went for after the
information on the bin laden family how
many of the brothers or i don't even
know if they're all brothers uh but how
many of the family the 50 children are
involved in the bin laden businesses
well that's a good question there's not
a whole lot of information my sense is
that most of them have some kind of
stake in the business uh financially uh
exactly how many participate uh
i think there's you know seven or eight
or maybe a dozen who are in key
leadership positions in the in the
business uh just judging from looking at
the board of directors and things like
that
um
you know it's it's a little hard to know
in fact it's a little hard to know
exactly what financial relationship
osama bin laden has with the business uh
we've been told different things at
different times
my best understanding
is that you know he inherited some stock
in the business from his father who died
in a plane crash in in the late 60s
uh it took him i think many years and
and the rest of the family sort of clear
up the estate and decide who got what
and then uh when there was a rupture
with the rest of the family uh
he you know he lost his saudi
citizenship he moved to sudan and my
understanding is that his holdings in
the company are frozen uh and maybe in a
trust of some kind but
it's difficult you know i don't have we
don't have enough information to
untangle the the whole finances of the
of the saudi bin laden group edwardsburg
michigan for dan golden of the wall
street journal go ahead please
yes first of all i'd like to say that i
think that the lady that had called
before
is commendable in the fact that she
is trying to honor our president but i
think when we stop asking questions and
when we stop wondering what's going on
with our government in our country we
belittle ourselves
and we might lose out on something
that's really important to ourselves
i think this man has done a great job on
trying to find information and given us
information so that we can ask questions
and i don't think that he was trying to
do anything but find information out
[Music]
i'm kind of concerned
about people still being able to come
over here and
take airline
flight
oh what's the word i want
take more
schooling for that
i wish somebody would look into that
because they said that's not
supposed to be against the law well
hey
wake up people
we need new laws we need our government
to start making new laws for the new
times and they're not doing that thanks
any comment mr golden well i think she
you know
she's certainly correct in that there is
a lot of concern about how easy it is to
get a visa to come to this country i'd
also like to say you know about the the
bin laden family that uh
you know even more than just disowning
usama i mean they have been uh good
allies to the us in a number of ways
they they uh after the uh the truck
bombing in saudi arabia in 1996 when
when a bunch of american servicemen were
killed you know they built uh new
barracks for the servicemen they were
helpful to us in the gulf war so that
it's they're not simply wealthy saudi
businessmen looking to make money in the
u.s they've been uh strong uh allies to
us in uh in time of need and uh you know
that that should definitely be mentioned
and you know as well as saudi arabia is
a country where a lot of the uh politics
and society are built on kind of
extended family networks so for them to
uh repudiate a brother is uh is a pretty
strong move to make and should be given
credit this uh
email
is not signed by a person but says where
is robert rubin now
and uh is there anything ethically or
morally different between what he's
doing and what say carlucci is doing is
from maui hawaii
i'm not familiar with what mr rubin's
activities now
let's well let me let me just ask them a
general question is there anything
ethically or morally wrong from a former
high executive in any administration
from going into business using their
former contacts to help their business
uh proliferate
well i think there are ethical questions
about it not speaking about the case
which i'm dealing with in particular but
in general a lot of states
i know have laws that restrict former
officials from going into business right
away with people that they've uh done
business with while in the government
they'll have a six month or one year or
a longer waiting period because
obviously somebody who has just left
office may be in a position to exercise
undue influence on on a contract being
awarded or on uh
you know some other piece of public
business that affects private enterprise
so obviously in a general way that
there's long been an issue of the
revolving door and the ethical questions
that it raises if you've just joined us
daniel golden wrote an article on the
september 27th
page three of the wall street journal
about the bin laden family and its
connection to the carlisle group and
that connection to jim baker and frank
carlucci and former president bush he is
in boston this morning we said earlier
that he's sitting in front of a
photograph he's actually sitting in
front of what i guess would be a rear
projection camera with uh because those
ship those boats behind you are moving
so i suspect that's a video tape is that
or is that a picture out of a window
i haven't actually looked behind me when
i look in front of me i see a window but
it's got uh you know it's got drapes on
it so i'm not sure why no there's a view
of boston out there but it's not very
clear to me mr mr golden is uh resides
in belmont massachusetts do i remember
correctly that's where uh the john birch
society is located or was uh i think it
was located there uh you know my
understanding is it isn't anymore which
i'm glad about san francisco california
next for daniel golden uh good morning
i'm mr golden um i listen to you and i
and i find myself thinking that you
sound like the proverbial politician who
calls
his opponent a thespian and expects it
to have some
impact and and i wonder
what is it about the fact that there's a
business relationship between the
carlyle group and the bin laden family
which is a
large
you know industrial family in saudi
arabia which you pointed out in your
article
why why should that cause anybody any
concern whatsoever
um why is that an issue
given the fact that osama is estranged
from that family
well as as i believe i said before he's
estranged from the principal members of
the family but uh you know sort of
intelligence experts believe that he's
still in contact with some members of
the family as i said there's there's a
dispute over his financial stake in the
business uh which he has some still some
relationship to although the the money's
frozen
um he has a brother-in-law who's been
identified as a terrorist uh so these
are all reasons why at least i think
it's worth uh worth
a newspaper article to uh to look at the
relationship between the bin laden
family and uh and the carlisle group and
american business any follow-up caller
yeah i mean again i've had some
familiarity with carlyle group
investments over the years i know they
were in america's favorite chicken you
know one one example um
and and i and again i i i understand
that the connection between the family
and osama may be a little murky and is
not a
simple black and white estrangement
but again i i my impression is that you
are making an implication about the bin
laden family as a business organization
and the carlyle group which is a more
nefarious implication that is probably
warranted thanks mr golden yeah i should
add one other thing which is that uh
according to the biographies i've read
of mr bin laden
usama he uh
used uh you know his family sort of
business network uh it helped him
uh you know get financial and other
kinds of resources to make contact i
mean it's a network that he used as he
was building up to uh
you know the kind of notorious position
he has today so that that's another
reason why it it bears scrutiny and as
for the carlyle group uh
you know i think that uh
you know it's interesting that this is
one place that they accepted money from
and uh
you know i think that if they they
didn't feel a bit queasy about it they
probably would have been willing to be
quoted in the paper and probably would
have come on this show
stuttgart germany next for dan golden
good morning good morning sir thank god
for c-stand i watch every chance i get
it so much it's late afternoon here in
germany i uh transplanted over here
because of the smoke and mirrors
does mr golden happen to know why the
government is lying to us anthrax as
being a vaccine being made in lansing
michigan they don't have the contract to
make it for civilians because they've
had trouble with the food drug
administration
also there is so much smoke and mirrors
going on about other things they don't
want panic they don't want to know let
you know about the rotary engine fuel
cells or any of those things and a
carburetor gets much greater mileage
they don't tell you how gasoline uh can
be used out of corn and would help the
farmers there are so many things that
that the government does good does evil
evil does good and the key word is logic
and the key word that they don't want to
happen in america is panic dan golden
uh well yeah i'm not really an anthrax
expert i i can't help him there
go back to your article because the
implication is made
that
the carlisle group continued to do
business uh with the bin laden family
even after
the 1993
world trade center bombing at that time
did you ask anybody about why they
continued after that because it's in the
article
well yeah i think that the relationship
uh from the carla group's account
started in 1994 so uh i think that uh
you know as i've said they felt uh
assured or so so they say that there
wasn't a connection between the family
the rest of the family and usama
and they were looking for
more contacts in saudi arabia as i say
the bin laden family is very close to
the royal family it's close to other
wealthy families in saudi arabia and the
carlisle group
i think was looking to cultivate the
investors in that region which is of
course a very uh well-off project got
some very well-off
you know prosperous millionaires and
billionaires with money to invest
palmdale california for dan golden
you're next
hi i'd like to thank mr goldwyn for
having the courage to shed the light on
this family i'm really tired of the
hypocrisy and the stupidity of the right
wing and
how they are just into the big money and
into the oil to the lady from tampa
florida wake up get your head out of the
sand the bush family and corruptness go
hand in hand we have the iran contra
scandal the stolen election even now
with um the former resident at the white
house if you want to protest him you
have to be behind a first amendment zone
tape you can't even
you know
express your
disgust or you or anything with him
because you have to stand behind a
certain area i just i just really thank
mr golden uh for having the courage to
shed the light i mean it's wonderful and
to the man from san francisco if this
were clinton instead of bush the bush
family we would be spending billions of
dollars investigating him i'm just i'm
really tired of the hypocrisy mr golden
uh any retribution whatsoever from the
bush administration when this article
came out
no
as i said it was largely ignored there
for the first week or two and only now
is it getting this kind of ground swell
and is there any fear though in a wall
street journal that an article like this
would uh lead to
this administration during a war time to
exclude you from some of the pools and
things that happen at the defense
department
well i i haven't heard anything like
that and you know in my part uh you know
i'm not based in washington i'm based in
boston i don't cover the administration
on a regular basis so it wouldn't affect
me personally and i haven't heard from
anybody in the washington bureau
any indication that this article was
taken adversely i think you know it was
seen as a very balanced account um as
was my prior article on on the bin laden
group and its connections with american
business i mean i think it was seen as
newsworthy and you know we've emphasized
that the the bin laden family group uh
as i said aided the uh the us military
in in in crucial times and uh
you know is is has disowned usama so i
think they were they were grateful for
the even-handed approach dan gold has
been at the wall street journal for two
years we go next to pearl river new york
good morning
good morning
i was wondering why the press doesn't
seem to go after the other side of the
story
into the terrorists and the
investigation of them
they seem to be on any superhighways of
information that the government has
created
they follow up and go into every nook
and cranny but they don't seem to create
their own
sources to bring new information in why
what are you talking about caller give
us some idea
what do you want them to do
well who are all these terrorists
are they over there investigating them
are they looking into that well there
have been reams of copying the
newspapers here on the east coast about
these terrorists and who they are only
the ones that were identified by the fbi
and talked about as a total picture of
what government information there is
there is no investigative reporting done
that's bringing new stuff in
or following them down and following all
the leads on them as actively as they
are you know what missile was shot and
what was the name on it
i i would comment that uh i mean there
has been obviously pages and pages and
pages and pages written about the
hijackers and whatever we can find out
about their associates but i'd add you
know in fairness to the to the caller's
point it is an extraordinarily difficult
story to cover uh uh be partly because
uh the investigation understandably is
being played very close to the vest so
it's very hard to find out for example
the names of the people who have been
detained in the investigation and which
ones are considered uh
you know to have terrorist connections
and which ones are just being detained
because of uh
immigration uh
violations
and uh you know even if you know the
names it's very hard to know exactly on
what basis uh what facts are held
there's not been a lot of information
given out in the courts
so a lot of our normal sources of
information are dried up there's not a
lot of public documents
there's not a lot of
you know lawyers willing to talk and so
reporters as a result are forced to rely
heavily on law enforcement sources
and uh there's a couple problems with
that obviously law enforcement sources
are are just as biased as any other
source uh what they find they also have
incomplete information what they find
out one day may not prove to be true the
next day and it just makes it very
difficult when the you know all the
trails simply lead back to
you know whatever fbi or atf or customs
person uh you may be able to persuade to
give you a few dribs and drabs in your
september 27th article here's what you
say you say a u.s inquiry
into bin laden family business dealings
could brush against some big names
associated with the us government former
president bush
said through his chief of staff gene
baker that he recalled only one meeting
with the bin laden family which took
place in november 1998. ms becker
confirmed that there was a second
meeting in january 2000 after being read
the ex-president's subsequent thank you
note president bush does not have a
relationship with the bin laden family
says miss becker he's met them twice
again i go back to these thank you notes
that were so famous when he was
president um
you you actually saw the thank you note
or they did you just were read the words
well i don't want to get into exactly
the specifics of the source material i
dealt with but uh you know uh obviously
that was not a uh you know that was
absolutely correct the text as you read
it what advantage is it to the bin laden
family
that this kind of an article be printed
well i i'm not sure it's to their
advantage or disadvantage uh
you know i mean to their advantage would
be the parts of the story where we point
out that they've disowned osama and
they've been helpful to the u.s
uh to their disadvantage might be that
some of their uh uh business partners in
the united states might be might be
embarrassed and run for cover and and
not be eager to do business with them
anymore but you know that's not a
consideration i have in mind
you also say in the article mr baker
meaning jim baker visited the bin laden
family both 98 and 99 according to
people close to the family in the second
trip he traveled on a family plane mr
baker declined comment as did mr
carluccio pass chairman of nortel
networks corp which has partnered with
saudi bin laden group on
telecommunications ventures again it
appears when you read the article that
the bin laden has wanted you and us to
know that they were all close to this
carlyle group
no i don't think so they did not
initiate the the story and i don't think
you know my sense is that the bin laden
family is not exactly uh eager for
publicity right now scottsdale arizona
for dan golden of the wall street
journal good morning good morning you're
on the air uh what i wanted to say was
that it sounds like from your previous
guest chris matthews and this guest that
that you're insinuating that this war is
being fought in afghanistan over oil and
from the last time i checked it was
about 6 000 dead americans so i it just
seems like there's peop liberals calling
in with these conspiracy theories about
the bushes
and the gulf war and whatnot and and i
don't think you can say that this war is
being fought over oil
don't go away i'll let mr golden react
and then you can come back at him go
ahead yeah i actually want to want to
continue a point i made before uh
because i'm certainly not trying to
imply that it's being fought over over
oil though that's obviously always been
a big issue in the mideast uh
before when i said that the bin laden
family was uh wasn't eager for publicity
i just wanted to elaborate on that i
mean one can have some some sympathy for
the the bin laden family as opposed to
usama in that
they're kind of trapped between two
worlds they uh you know back in in saudi
arabia they have to pass muster with the
fundamentalists i mean they have
contracts to renovate the mosques at
mecca and medina and other holy places
and if they don't appear suitably
fundamentalist and strict in the islamic
sense they might lose those contracts on
the other hand they have a lot of
friends in the united states
they
some of their children the next
generation were born here and are
citizens here a lot of them have been
educated at american you know prep
schools and universities
and uh you know so they they want to
they're they want to be on both sides at
a time when the when the world is is
rapidly polarizing and
this was symbolized for me i was told
that one one member of the bin laden
family when he's in the united states
he's clean-shaven but when he goes back
to saudi arabia he grows a beard because
that's what good muslims should do let
me ask the caller in scottsdale is this
kind of a story fair game at this time
well what i want to know is does his
story state all these things that he
just told me in fairness to you know to
explain a little bit more about the bin
laden's relation or who they are and you
know just does his story go into those
things
it goes into some of them uh some of
them there wasn't space for and some of
the other stuff i just mentioned i
didn't know at the time i wrote it
well there was a i think a 60 minutes
piece or one of those
network pieces where they talked to a
doctor who was a close friend of the bin
laden saying exactly the same thing that
you did that when they get on an
airplane and come over here they take
off
their garb and they
shave clean and all that i mean is this
cynical or what
well i think you could see it as cynical
but you could also see it as kind of sad
why
well because as i was saying that
they've got these two different worlds
that they're in between and
obviously it's not you know it's not a
tragedy or anything but i think it's
it's difficult for people who built up a
huge business in saudi arabia based on
sort of uh good relations with the rest
of the world to see it kind of uh
crumbling in both places montreal canada
for dan golden you're next good morning
hello good morning how are you fine sir
thanks for joining us what would you
like to say yeah i
work for a law firm in montreal
and we handle
many many commercial contracts in nova
scotia
and one one which we worked on was
the new york times which owns
considerable property in nova scotia
including their
hot mills and ships and you name it
all aboveboard
but they are the new york times in nova
scotia also has joint ventures with the
carlyle group
and all again above board
sir
can i ask you a question certainly as a
lawyer how are you able to even discuss
this i can discuss it because you don't
know who i am and i thought i could add
something to the conversation i don't
mind you calling i just wondered from a
standpoint of being in the house as long
as i don't go into the details i have no
problem with it so what are you saying
what's the point of your uh your my
point is that
uh your show seems to be saying
there's something nefarious
about carlyle
and former president bush
having had contacts in the past
with this the middle east group
and so far
i would sum the article up as so what
now the salksburg won the new york times
have contacts with that same group
and they have contacts with groups in
israel
thanks
is your story uh nefarious
uh no i don't think it's it's i don't
think it's either nefarious or a
disgrace to journalism you know as a
previous caller put it i i think it i
don't think it's the the most important
investigative story ever written but i
think it adds a little to the context
for people trying to understand uh what
the world's like today which is pretty
much what i was trying to do have you
tried to get the carlyle group on the
record after your story came out again
uh no i haven't because
as i mentioned before i'm exploring some
leads but until they they go a little
farther i don't have enough to ask the
carlyle group about to to make it
worthwhile and our producer has told me
that
they did not call us back last night
so that we're still waiting for a call
and love to have them come on and
explain the whole company the whole
outfit frank carlucci or jim baker
anyone would be welcome here to talk
about it let's go to columbia missouri
you're on the air yes hi um
i believe this whole issue is about
guilt by association
uh i agree with the earlier caller who
said that you're trying to smear the
reputation of legitimate businesses
and officials who dealt with the binding
family
um the binary family cannot have any
control on osama bin laden the guy is an
adult he can do anything he wants and if
he dealt with the connections that he
his family had with and other legitimate
businesses
and it's not their fault
and it would be the fault of the
businesses who who directly dealt with
osama bin laden and that's it caller
where is the smear here well number one
he has absolutely no reason to say
that you know i mean to me in my opinion
what he's saying is well you know and
he's dealing with the bill and belonging
family uh you know because they are
relatives of that terrorist they're also
terrorists because otherwise this will
not have any reason to be written about
let me let me ask the caller one
question do you think that we at the
wall street journal simply should not
have printed this story that that it
wasn't sufficiently newsworthy to put in
the paper that uh former president bush
uh former secretary of state baker and
former secretary of defense carlucci had
visited the bin laden family
headquarters within the last couple
years and were in had a financial
relationship with them do you think that
that's not even worthy of uh going in an
american publication the reason why i
say yes i think that there is no reason
to write about it because they they are
a legitimate business aren't they
did they deal with any terrorists are
they terrorists if osama bin laden dealt
with the carlochis and the bush himself
yes i will agree with you totally and
this is miss worthy but the fact that
example i'll put myself in their
situation if one of my relatives was
a
a criminal i have no fault to it okay
and my reputation myself should not be
punished for it do you understand what i
mean yeah well it says this is an adult
he's not a child it's not like they are
uh they're able to control him or
they're able to do anything about it as
a matter of fact as you said they have
cut him off therefore it's not
newsworthy
what you are trying to say in my opinion
and you and the way i conclude from from
what you have done is not because this
is newsworthy it's because you're trying
to say to any type of legitimate
businesses do not deal with the arabs do
not deal with that part of the world
because otherwise we're going to
smear you i mean your reputation that's
what you're trying to say because i
really cannot find any reason why they
cannot deal with the bin laden family
thanks
mr gold yeah as as i said before the the
relationship between the family members
and usama is a little bit murky uh the
families formally disowned him the the
brothers who run the family have no
contact with him there were reports that
he called uh his mother or stepmother i
wasn't clear which a couple days before
september 11th to uh
uh to let her know that something big
was going to happen uh he does have a
brother-in-law sister's husband who's
been identified as a terrorist by
philippine law enforcement authorities
uh he he did have a financial stake in
the company and it's unclear what has
happened to that
i think there's enough reason to at
least raise the question about the
family mr let me go to the person's
point though and see if you what your
comment would be on that
isn't it safe to assume that a lot of ex
uh
american
public policy officials and
administration
participants are doing business today
with the israelis
i i'm just not familiar enough with that
to say but it sounds reasonable to me
let's go next to nassau in the bahamas
for dan goldman go ahead please yes good
morning gentlemen morning
uh i do i do agree with the last caller
that i i
i know that sometimes
it looks like he is trying to vilify
bush simply because
bush or whatever has some
connections with the bin laden family
and you cannot for instance me
i know many families the members of the
families are fantastic but there's one
bad apple okay all of a sudden i'm a bad
guy i say give the guy a break stop
vilifying and in my personal opinion
i believe the author has a personal
agenda there's more behind his reporting
of this just to simply report he says oh
don't you think it's worth reporting
yada yada i say to him to this i say to
him this sometimes when you report it's
not just for the sake of reporting but
the personal agenda of the report that
has to be taken just like a filmmaker
has a point of view you cannot do a
completely
uh
disassociate yourself from the kind of
film you are making or the kind of peace
you are reporting you always have a
personal agenda what is the reason just
to report no i say there are reasons
behind persons reporting what they're
reporting what is the author's actual
agenda against this bush man thanks
i can just tell you that you know i have
no personal agenda other than uh you
know trying to follow my nose toward a
good story and i would differentiate
between a film which i would agree is a
very personal statement and a news story
which i don't think is such a personal
statement are you surprised at the
number of calls that have come in this
morning that uh
think this is not a story yeah i mean i
think i perceive a a certain
defensiveness as if uh
you know somehow the story were
unpatriotic
uh you know and all i can say is those
aren't the kind of considerations that
motivate me when i when i research a
story and on this particular story you
know i had
two co-authors an editor in boston
editors in new york i mean it was a
group decision to uh
to report and run this story and uh what
was their reaction to this
uh
you know they liked the story or they
wouldn't have put in the paper you know
it was not heavily rewritten or edited
or anything there was not there was not
this kind of discussion i mean i think
everybody felt that it was sufficiently
newsworthy now they didn't put it on
page one they put it on page three which
i think was a reflection that they
didn't want to make too much of it but
obviously they you know page three is a
is a good placement and they felt it was
worth the attention of the american
public silmar california for dan golden
just a couple minutes left go ahead
please okay uh
thank you brian uh
i think i can give you a few places to
look for a little more information mr
golden uh i'm not sure if you i'm not
sure if you've read uh
the book uh false prophets which was
about the bcci scandal okay this went on
in the 80s and the 70s came to light in
the late 80s when george bush senior was
the president
there's a lot of information that
intertwines with your story
in that book okay i've read the book
several times in fact i just read it two
days ago what's the fellas what's the
fella's name pardon me what is the
fella's name
the bc or the book no the book yeah oh
uh
you know i i can it's probably in the
other room in my bedroom well but there
was a book written like this that was uh
discredited and the man i don't believe
is alive anymore no this is a book
that's written by two to two fellows
uh it hasn't been discredited uh
i think i think while mr golden is
answering this you ought to go get the
book so that we don't just leave the
information there without the source
brian i i have it and i want to tell you
another book to look for and believe me
you're on the right track sir hold on
i'm going to get the book go ahead mr
golden well there's uh you know i have a
passing familiar familiarity with the
bcci scandal but now i'm no expert on it
but there's been a number of books
written on it and uh there's no question
that uh it's the fact that one of the
leading figures in that was nate was
named mafus
he was another
uh he was another uh wealthy saudi
arabian a banker and uh i think he's
he's friends with and has many ties with
with the bin ladens what do you is a
caller back
oh i'm back yeah what's the book okay
the book is false prophets it's written
by peter truell and larry gerwin
okay true peter truell was a wall street
journal reporter there you have it okay
so you can talk to him personally now
what you said is right about mafus
there's a lot of other people involved
in that too george w is involved in it
jeb is involved in it george senior is
involved in it they're all they're all
hooked up carlisle i mean carlucci is
involved was involved in the bcci thing
uh clark clifford many many high
big
wig political figures are involved with
the bccei scandal or in hatch
but i don't want to go into that you're
on the right track there's another book
that you can look at
uh called clinton bush in the cia
and that was written by
uh
i forget who was ghost written by but
the guy who was the memoirs of was a guy
named terry reed
you might want to look at that book all
right sir thanks
i think there's another book also about
bcci calling something like bank of
crooks and criminals something like that
and yeah there's no question that that's
a whole
you know ripe complicated area involving
uh you know as players various saudi
arabian billionaires and the bush family
in some degree but i just uh you know
you really need a scorecard to
understand the bcci but
it definitely relates in some way we
have one more call for you and we'll
wrap it up cleveland ohio you're on the
air
uh
yes uh
i was going to ask mr goldman if he
thought it was worth looking into uh
what oil companies are prospering
from this war and what defense
contractors are prospering from it
thanks
well that kind of thing i think is
always worth looking into but i don't
know yet what it would turn up
thank you dan golden and once again it's
on it's a september 27th article in the
wall street journal you say it's
available on the website if people don't
subscribe to that or can't get into it
is there any other way to get it
uh that's a good question i mean they
can email me a request for a copy i
guess uh at dan.golden at wsj.com and
i'll try and accommodate them
dan.golden
at wsj.com
right and we appreciate you coming on
the program thank you very much thank
you dan golden in boston this morning as
we said earlier he is
from amherst massachusetts was at the
boston globe for some 18 years and has
been the wall street journal for the
last two years and wrote that piece with
two others on september the 27th
tomorrow morning on the washington
journal stacy palmer the editor of the
chronicle of philanthropy
and the issue will be what's happening
to all this money that's been generated
some 1.4 billion already a lot of
complaints showing up in the media about
folks at ground zero not getting the
money robert oakley former u.s
ambassador to pakistan
james grimaldi a washington post
reporter the topic will be u.s
immigration laws then on sunday bill
crystal the editor of the weekly
standard and ken alabeck former first
deputy chief of the soviet biological
weapons program he now lives here in the
washington dc area and this morning at
11 o'clock if you're interested the
chinese central television
newscast coming up in about an hour
which will give you an update on the
president's trip over there thank you
for joining us and have a nice weekend
you